donald trump is the wrong president for
our country
he has had more than enough time to
prove that he can do the job but he
is clearly in over his head former first
lady michelle obama calls on social
media companies to permanently ban
donald trump from their platforms
following wednesday's attack on the u.s
capitol by the president's supporters
congressional leaders have pleaded for
president trump to call
off the protesters on wednesday
pro-trump extremists stormed the
historic building
claiming election fraud and protesting
the ratification of president-elect
joe biden's electoral college victory in
the 2020 election
four people died at least 13 police
officers were injured and
52 people were arrested late today he
did
tweet a video in which he repeated his
false claims
that the election was stolen from him
all that came
after trump held a rally earlier in the
day where he encouraged the crowd to hit
up the capitol
we're gonna walk down and i'll be there
with you we're gonna walk down
we're gonna walk down anyone you want
but i think right here we're going to
walk down
to the capitol
and we're going to cheer on our brave
senators and congressmen and women
and we're probably not going to be
cheering so much for
some of them in response to the riot
facebook announced on thursday that it
was
banning trump until at least january
20th
the end of his presidential term twitter
has not yet banned trump but on
wednesday the site removed a handful of
tweets posted by the president
and blocked him from posting for 12
hours
and youtube removed a video trump posted
wednesday
in which he praised the rioters and
continued to make false claims about the
2020 election
but in a statement released on thursday
michelle
implored them to do more and stop
enabling this
monstrous behavior by quote permanently
banning this man from their platforms
and putting in place policies to prevent
their technology from being used by the
nation's leaders
to fuel insurrection trump has often
said that he uses social platforms to
bypass what he calls the fake news media
on twitter trump has 88.7 million
followers which makes him the sixth most
followed person on the social site
former president barack obama is first
with
128 million they are acting in the
smallest
possible way a criminal way to attack
the capital
occupy it and violate federal law in
full public view in pursuit of something
they consider to be lofty
in her statement michelle also described
her horror at watching the mob of people
at the capitol
they set up gallows they proudly waved
the traitorous flag of the confederacy
through the halls
they desecrated the center of american
government
she added that the far right-wing media
along with the president
were responsible for what happened the
day was a fulfillment of the wishes of
an infantile and
unpatriotic president who can't handle
the truth of his own failures
and the wreckage lays at the feet of a
party and media apparatus that gleefully
cheered him on knowing full well the
possibility of consequences like these
and the former flotus said in order for
our nation to heal
we each need to do our part quote to
reach out
to listen and to hold tight to the truth
and values that have always led this
country forward
it will be an uncomfortable sometimes
painful process
but if we enter into it with an honest
and unwavering love of our country
then maybe we can finally start to heal